This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Professor C.T. Wen teaches philosophy at the University of Utah, and he says the reason he got into this field is because he has drawn to life's big questions. These weird, romantic, bizarre questions, like, about the meaning of life. And what is art for? Like, are we just wasting our time doing our dumb hobbies or is it the best part of life? Those were the questions I cared about. But when he started teaching philosophy, T learned that what makes a good philosopher at a prestigious school had less to do with pursuing curiosity and had more to do with metrics.
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马斯。C.T. 温教授在犹他大学教授哲学，他说他之所以进入这个领域，是因为他被人生中的重大问题所吸引。那些古怪、浪漫、离奇的问题，比如关于生命的意义。艺术是为了什么？比如，我们是在浪费时间做那些愚蠢的爱好，还是说这才是生命中最美好的部分？这些是我关心的问题。但当他开始教哲学时，温教授了解到，在名校成为一名优秀的哲学家，与追求好奇心关系不大，而与指标关系更大。
Your value as a philosopher seemed based on whether your papers were getting published in highly ranked philosophy journals. There's no moment where anyone told me to care about it, but everybody just talks in that language. And suddenly you just find yourself kind of automatically thinking that your goal is to publish in the top-ranked journals. And that that's what success means in philosophy. Suddenly, all the joy was sucked out of this thing that he loved so much. I was so bored with what I was writing because I was trying to go up this list and so miserable that I was going to quit the profession after like having burned 10 years in it. Instead of giving up, T decided to do something that seemed like career suicide. He threw out those metrics of success and went after something harder to measure, his own curiosity.
作为一名哲学家，你的价值似乎取决于你的论文是否发表在排名靠前的哲学期刊上。没有人明确告诉过我必须在意这些，但每个人都在用那种语言交流。突然之间，你会发现自己似乎自动地认为，你的目标就是在顶级期刊上发表文章。这就是哲学领域所谓的成功。突然间，他所热爱的事物中所有的乐趣都被抽干了。我对自己写的东西感到非常厌倦，因为我一直在试图攀登那个排名列表，我感到非常痛苦，以至于在从事这个行业10年后，我差点就要放弃了。温教授没有放弃，而是决定做一件看起来像是职业自杀的事情。他抛弃了那些成功的指标，转而追求更难衡量的事物——他自己的好奇心。
This is the story C.T. Wendt uses to open his latest book, The Score, How to Stop Playing Someone Else's Game. In it, T expands the definition of games to encompass all the ways metrics and scoring systems play out in our lives for good and for ill, from those dreaded philosophy journal rankings to duolingo, step counting, and beyond. I love this book, and I was so excited to talk to T about it. We had a delightfully meandering conversation about the philosophy of games, the trap of metrics and how to make sure we're playing the game we want to be playing. Our chat started with me asking T to define a concept he coined called value capture. Value capture is what happens when your own values are rich or subtle or developing in that direction.
这就是C.T. 温在开篇讲述的故事，出自他的新书《得分：如何停止玩别人的游戏》（The Score, How to Stop Playing Someone Else's Game）。在书中，温教授将游戏的定义扩展到涵盖了指标和评分系统在我们生活中发挥作用的所有方式，无论好坏，从那些令人恐惧的哲学期刊排名到多邻国（Duolingo）、步数统计等等。我非常喜欢这本书，也很高兴能与温教授讨论它。我们进行了一场令人愉悦的、漫谈式的对话，探讨了游戏哲学、指标陷阱，以及如何确保我们玩的是我们自己想玩的游戏。我们的谈话始于我请温教授定义他创造的一个概念——“价值捕获”（value capture）。价值捕获是指当你的价值观本身很丰富、微妙或正在向那个方向发展时所发生的事情。
And then you get put in a social setting, an institution or with a technology that feeds you simplified, typically quantified versions of your values. And then the simplified version to take over. You have been here. You have been value captured. It happens all the time. Maybe you start going to school because you want to learn or you start walking more for your health. But then you get focused on a metric like getting all A's or counting steps. And suddenly you're very far from the values that drove you to do those things in the first place. This kind of dynamic is everywhere. One of my favorite examples. A lot of these things are so insidious that I hadn't realized the degree to which I internalized this. And I've been working on this stuff for like five years. And I was sitting there watching my kid being like, you know, I should reduce his screen time. So screen time is a massive metric for a lot of this. But then if you think about it, it's a crap metric. One week, my screen time skyrocketed. The reason my screen time skyrocketed was I was reading two different translations of Kant on my iPad.
然后你被置于一个社会环境、一个机构中，或者使用一种技术，它为你提供简化后的、通常是量化版本的价值观。接着，这个简化版本就会接管一切。你已经身处其中了。你已经被“价值捕获”了。这种情况时有发生。也许你开始上学是因为你想学习，或者你为了健康开始多走路。但后来你开始关注一个指标，比如拿到全A或者计算步数。突然之间，你离最初驱使你做这些事情的价值观已经非常遥远了。这种动态无处不在。我最喜欢的例子之一是，很多这类事情非常隐蔽，以至于我都没有意识到自己内化了这种程度。我研究这些东西已经五年了。我坐在那里看着我的孩子，心想，你知道吗，我应该减少他的屏幕时间。所以屏幕时间对很多人来说是一个巨大的指标。但如果你仔细想想，这是一个糟糕的指标。有一周，我的屏幕时间激增。我屏幕时间激增的原因是我在iPad上阅读康德的两种不同译本。
Right? That's not, that is not a bad thing for me to do. But I was watching my kid. I'm like, oh, I'm supposed to reduce his screen time. And one of the things I noticed is that sometimes, when he's on his screen, he's watching the dumbest possible ASMR videos. Sometimes he is literally learning geopolitics. He's obsessed with videos that explain the history of the rise of World War I and World War II.
对吧？那不是，那对我来说不是一件坏事。但我当时在观察我的孩子。我想，哦，我应该减少他的屏幕时间。我注意到的一件事是，有时当他在看屏幕时，他看的是最愚蠢的ASMR视频。有时他确实是在学习地缘政治。他沉迷于那些解释第一次世界大战和第二次世界大战起因的视频。
He's nine. Sometimes he is playing dumb clicker games. Sometimes he's building architectural masterpieces in Minecraft with like coded logic gates. These are not the same thing, right? There's no way in which these are valuable in anything like the same amount. but it's very easy for a device to capture screen time. And I think this is part of my core worry here is that we're outsourcing our values to an external product or institution.
他才九岁。有时他在玩愚蠢的点击游戏。有时他在《我的世界》（Minecraft）中用编码逻辑门建造建筑杰作。这些不是同一回事，对吧？它们在任何方面都不可能具有相同的价值。但设备很容易捕捉到屏幕时间。我认为这是我核心担忧的一部分，即我们正在将我们的价值观外包给外部产品或机构。
And sometimes that's a classical story of evil. Somebody like some Machiavellian tells us what to value. But a lot of the times, like a lot of outsourcing, what we're outsourcing to is a process that's convenient at scale. What's determining how a lot of us parent is just that screen. time happens to be an easy thing for our devices to measure automatically without any particular input from us. T says that forcing the things we value into the sausage grinder of metrics can often flatten nuance and meaning in favor of generating a value that's more simple and measurable.
有时这是一个经典的邪恶故事。像马基雅维利主义者那样的人告诉我们该重视什么。但很多时候，就像许多外包一样，我们外包给的是一个在大规模应用下很方便的过程。决定我们许多人如何育儿的，仅仅是屏幕时间恰好是我们的设备无需我们特别输入就能自动轻松测量的事情。温教授说，将我们重视的事物强行塞进指标的绞肉机中，往往会抹平细微差别和意义，转而生成一种更简单、可衡量的价值。
It is and often feels awful and reductive, and yet we can't help being seduced by it. Why do you think it is that you and others actually find this kind of value capture framework so tempting and rewarding enough that pulls you into this type of engagement? I mean, life is full of these complicated existential value clashes where you have to make these nauseating decisions. I mean, I think every day I'm faced with the decision of whether to spend more time playing with my kids or more time doing hobbies I enjoy or more time like staying up late doing. you ask your email. That's a terrifying decision that, like, asks me to weigh these very different values. But if you automate it, if you decide there's only one thing that's important and that everything feeds into that thing in a mechanically measurable way, suddenly you're sheltered from the existential storm. You're safe. So that's one answer. The second answer is the seductiveness
这确实让人感觉糟糕且具有还原性，然而我们却无法抗拒它的诱惑。你认为为什么你和其他人实际上会觉得这种“价值捕获”框架如此诱人且有回报，以至于让你陷入这种参与中？我的意思是，生活充满了这些复杂的生存价值冲突，你必须做出这些令人作呕的决定。我的意思是，我想我每天都面临着决定：是花更多时间陪孩子玩，还是花更多时间做我喜欢的爱好，或者花更多时间熬夜处理你的电子邮件。这是一个可怕的决定，它要求我权衡这些非常不同的价值观。但如果你将其自动化，如果你决定只有一件事是重要的，并且一切都以一种机械可衡量的方式服务于那件事，突然之间，你就躲过了生存的风暴。你是安全的。所以这是一个答案。第二个答案是诱惑力。
is making yourself comprehensible and communicable to other people. Right? Like when I, I mean, This is something I do, I have done, and I'm very embarrassed about. So, you know, while I was researching this book and looking at scoring systems, I started reading about yo-yo. And I got reading into yo-yoing. Yoyoing is super interesting. Modern yoyoing. There's been technology revolutions. It's gotten super complicated.
是让自己变得易于理解和与他人交流。对吧？就像我，我的意思是，这是我做过的事情，我做过，而且我对此感到非常尴尬。所以，你知道，当我在研究这本书并查看评分系统时，我开始阅读关于溜溜球的内容。我开始研究玩溜溜球。玩溜溜球超级有趣。现代溜溜球。技术发生了革命。它变得超级复杂。
It blew up with skateboarding. Really interesting and intricate topological structures you build. But I just want you to imagine me being an apparently adult philosophy professor at a dinner party, having to tell other people. that I've been goddamn yo-yoing in my free time. People look at me like I've gone nuts, and they look at me like I'm making a joke. Because trying to explain, I mean, I think in any of your, anybody, in any weird obsession you have, right,
它随着滑板运动而兴起。非常有趣且复杂的拓扑结构。但我只是想让你想象一下，我作为一个看起来像成年人的哲学教授在晚宴上，不得不告诉别人我在业余时间一直在玩该死的溜溜球。人们看着我，就像我疯了一样，他们看着我，就像我在开玩笑。因为试图解释，我的意思是，我想在你的任何，任何人的任何奇怪的痴迷中，对吧，
when you actually get to the reason that's important, the reason that really moves you, it's not going to be very accessible to people that aren't deeply in that thing. T argues that one of the reasons yoyoing seems like a goof is because it doesn't really have understandable metrics. We excuse adults doing childish things if there's a record to beat or a score to measure. Those things would make yoying comprehensible and therefore would make you understood as a human. And understood instantly.
当你真正触及到它为什么重要的原因，那个真正打动你的原因时，它对那些没有深入其中人来说是不会太容易理解的。温教授认为，溜溜球看起来像个傻事的原因之一是它没有真正可理解的指标。如果有一个记录可以打破或一个分数可以衡量，我们就会原谅成年人做幼稚的事情。这些东西会使玩溜溜球变得可理解，从而使你被理解为一个人类。而且是瞬间被理解。
I think that's that's there's not, I mean, I think there are a lot of weird things that I love. That if someone trusts me and we spend some time together, I can transmit that. but metrics make you comprehensible instantly at scale. Hearing all this, it's easy to get the impression that scoring systems and metrics are more or less evil, that although they're alluring and their simplicity, which can help us feel understood, they end up draining the life out of everything we hold dear. But actually, T would disagree. He argues that in the right context, scoring systems can also be a way to unlock connection, creativity,
我认为，我的意思是，我认为我热爱很多奇怪的事情。如果有人信任我，我们花点时间在一起，我可以传达这一点。但指标让你在大规模范围内瞬间变得可理解。听到这一切，很容易让人觉得评分系统和指标或多或少是邪恶的，尽管它们在简单性上很诱人，可以帮助我们感到被理解，但它们最终会耗尽我们所珍视的一切生命力。但实际上，温教授会不同意。他认为在正确的背景下，评分系统也可以成为解锁联系、创造力的一种方式，
and even great joy in the place that this is most, readily visible is in gameplay. This is the paradox I got obsessed with, right? In games, scoring systems are beautiful. And then in metrics, scoring systems often seem like they're responsible for the worst part of our lives, for the destruction of education, to destruction of the arts, for the, like, destruction of the entire, like, environment, ecosystem and everything that we care about and the good.
甚至带来巨大的快乐，而这一点最显而易见的地方就是在游戏玩法中。这就是我沉迷的悖论，对吧？在游戏中，评分系统是美丽的。而在指标中，评分系统往往看起来像是我们生活中最糟糕部分的罪魁祸首，是教育的破坏、艺术的破坏，是像整个环境、生态系统以及我们关心的一切美好事物的破坏。
And, like, the thing I was trying to figure out is why scoring systems gave us such delightful play in games and gave us such soul-draining awfulness in metrics. T and I both love games and the design of games. And so we got really into talking about the magic of games and why exactly the scoring systems that hurt us in life can make games so rewarding. The funny thing about scoring systems is they are kind of little dictators. They tell you what you're supposed to want and value. And that's the weird thing. Scoring systems are little definitions of success and failure.
而且，我试图弄清楚的是，为什么评分系统在游戏中给了我们如此令人愉悦的玩法，而在指标中却给了我们如此令人灵魂枯竭的糟糕体验。我和温教授都热爱游戏和游戏设计。所以我们深入探讨了游戏的魔力，以及为什么生活中伤害我们的评分系统却能让游戏如此有回报。关于评分系统，有趣的一点是它们就像小独裁者。它们告诉你你应该想要什么和重视什么。这就是奇怪的地方。评分系统是成功和失败的小定义。
I think one of the biggest differences is that in games, those definitions are temporary and playful and under your control. And if you don't like it, you can throw it away and you never have to play again. And in institutions, they're authoritarian. Like a true philosopher, T considers all kinds of things games, board games, rock climbing, even fly fishing. And something that kept coming up for him and writing this book is the way that in games, scoring systems are an integral part of the fun. One of the things that got me writing this book was that I had spent a bunch of years trying to explain what games were, and I ended up saying that there were these beautiful structures that used scoring systems to give us alternate selves, that they gave us alternate desires, and a game just told you, make baskets, collect sheep,
我认为最大的区别之一是，在游戏中，这些定义是暂时的、有趣的，并且在你的控制之下。如果你不喜欢它，你可以把它扔掉，再也不用玩了。而在机构中，它们是威权主义的。像一位真正的哲学家一样，温教授将各种事物视为游戏，棋盘游戏、攀岩，甚至是飞钓。在写这本书的过程中，他不断提到的一点是，在游戏中，评分系统是乐趣不可或缺的一部分。让我写这本书的原因之一是，我花了好几年时间试图解释什么是游戏，最后我说它们是这些美丽的结构，利用评分系统给我们提供了替代自我，它们给了我们替代的欲望，而游戏只是告诉你，投篮，收集羊，
get to the top of the rock. And suddenly this thing you might never have cared about before, like getting to the top of some weird boulder. You're like, I need to do it. And then suddenly this whole new activity unlocks. Now, I love playing games with my kids. And since my kids are all over the country now, we plan game nights like months in advance.
爬到岩石顶端。突然之间，这个你以前可能从未关心过的事情，比如爬到某块奇怪的巨石顶端。你会觉得，我需要这样做。然后突然之间，这个全新的活动就被解锁了。现在，我喜欢和我的孩子们一起玩游戏。由于我的孩子们现在分散在全国各地，我们提前几个月计划游戏之夜。
And I am just competitive enough inside of a game to make it fun. I am not trying to lose. I am definitely trying to win. But I have to say, at the end of the night, or even at the end of any round of game, I cannot tell you who won that game. I cannot imagine caring about a game's outcome. I've never been able to describe this to people.
而且我在游戏里足够好胜，能让它变得有趣。我不是想输。我绝对是在努力赢。但我必须说，在晚上结束时，甚至在任何一轮游戏结束时，我无法告诉你谁赢了那场游戏。我无法想象会关心游戏的结果。我从来没能向人们描述这一点。
But T explained it to me that there are two types of play, striving play and achievement play. Achievement play is caring about winning, right? Achievement play is caring about, is playing because you actually want to win. Striving play is when you temporarily get yourself to want to win in order to experience the struggle. So the difference between the two
但温教授向我解释说，有两种类型的游戏，奋斗型游戏（striving play）和成就型游戏（achievement play）。成就型游戏是关心赢，对吧？成就型游戏是关心，是因为你真的想赢才玩。奋斗型游戏是当你暂时让自己想要赢，以便体验那种挣扎。所以两者之间的区别
is not about how intense you are about trying to win. You can be a striving player and be trying really intensely. The difference is the striving play values the experience, not if they win, but if the struggle was interesting. I am 100% a striver, but I still get wrapped up in the goal and drama of the game when I'm inside that game. So my family plays this game called Wingspan,
不在于你努力赢的程度有多强烈。你可以是一个奋斗型玩家，并且非常努力地尝试。区别在于奋斗型游戏重视的是体验，不是他们是否赢了，而是挣扎过程是否有趣。我百分之百是一个奋斗者，但当我在游戏里时，我仍然会被游戏的目标和戏剧性所吸引。所以我的家人玩一个叫《展翅翱翔》（Wingspan）的游戏，
and it's a beautiful little game that is more intuitive than all the little pieces and dense rules would have you to believe. But my stepdaughter hates this game. She hates Wigspan because I swear a lot when I play this game. There are often these scenarios when I need a certain card pull or a roll of the dice to make a very long plan strategy pay off. And I often don't get that card that I want. And hence the swearing. Since I am a very calm, non-volatile presence in her life, she hates hearing me swear.
这是一个美丽的小游戏，比所有那些小零件和密集的规则所让你相信的要直观得多。但我的继女讨厌这个游戏。她讨厌《展翅翱翔》，因为我玩这个游戏时骂人骂得很凶。经常会出现这样的场景：我需要抽到某张牌或掷出骰子来让一个非常漫长的计划策略奏效。而我经常抽不到我想要的牌。因此就会骂人。由于我在她生活中是一个非常冷静、不暴躁的存在，她讨厌听到我骂人。
And this game just brings it out of me more than most. I don't know why. But it turns out this freedom to swear to connive and compete, it's actually part of the magic of games. They give us this healthy arena for feelings that aren't so healthy in the real world. One of the interesting things about games is there a place where we're released to do something like that. Jan Huzenga, an anthropologist who studied games in the early 20th century, one of the first great scholars of play, he said that what makes sense,
而这个游戏比大多数游戏更能激发出我这一面。我不知道为什么。但事实证明，这种骂人、搞阴谋和竞争的自由，实际上是游戏魔力的一部分。它们为我们提供了一个健康的竞技场，用来释放那些在现实世界中不那么健康的感受。游戏有趣的一点是，它们是一个让我们被允许做类似事情的地方。约翰·赫伊津哈（Jan Huizinga），一位在20世纪初研究游戏的社会学家，最早的伟大游戏学者之一，他说是什么让，
games and play distinctive is that they occur in a magic circle where the meanings of what you do are screened off from ordinary life. So what this means is like, you know, if we're a close friend and then we're playing basketball against each other and you block my pass, I'm not going to come up after you afterwards and be like, how could you do that to me? You wound me, my friend. I thought we were close. Right. And because the meanings are screened off in that way, because the points, I mean, part of the point is the points are valueless, right? And we know that galactically, even if in the game we're really into it, which makes us release to be like, I try so hard in my life to be a nice person and to be a kind person. But there's a part of my brain that is a complete Machiavellian asshole. And I have to keep that under wraps most of the time. I don't get to do that. And in the game environment, because because it's so screened off from the rest of life in just this simple way, I can do that. It is part of the contract of gaming that when I play with my family or my friend, we can go all out. We can lie to each other. We can manipulate.
游戏和玩耍变得独特，是因为它们发生在“魔圈”（magic circle）中，你所做事情的意义与日常生活隔离开来。所以这意味着，你知道，如果我们是好朋友，然后我们在打篮球对抗，你封盖了我的传球，我不会在事后走过来对你说，你怎么能那样对我？你伤害了我，我的朋友。我以为我们很亲近。对吧。而且因为意义是以那种方式被屏蔽的，因为分数，我的意思是，部分重点是分数是毫无价值的，对吧？我们从宏观上知道这一点，即使在游戏中我们真的很投入，这让我们得以释放，就像，我在生活中非常努力地做一个好人，做一个善良的人。但我大脑中有一部分是一个彻头彻尾的马基雅维利式的混蛋。我大部分时间都必须把它藏起来。我没机会那样做。而在游戏环境中，因为它与生活的其他部分以这种简单的方式隔离开来，我可以那样做。游戏契约的一部分是，当我与家人或朋友一起玩时，我们可以全力以赴。我们可以互相撒谎。我们可以操纵。
We can deceive each other. We can look for each other's weaknesses and destroy each other because we know that the gaming environment has designed to turn that into an interesting struggle. Yeah. Yeah. A great example that you give of striving play is fly fishing, which is a thing I also, I don't, I love it. Like, I have a fly fishing cat. I went to a fly fishing class. I haven't sort of gotten off my ass to do fly fishing, but I just admire everything about it.
我们可以互相欺骗。我们可以寻找对方的弱点并摧毁对方，因为我们知道游戏环境的设计初衷就是将其转化为一场有趣的挣扎。是的。是的。你给出的奋斗型游戏的一个很好的例子是飞钓，这也是我，我不，我喜欢它。比如，我有一顶飞钓帽。我去上过飞钓课。我还没有真正下定决心去飞钓，但我只是钦佩关于它的一切。
And the more I learned about it, the more I admired it. Could you talk about the fly fishing in terms of striving play? Yeah. Fly fishing is really interesting to me. So I am in Utah, and in Utah, there are a lot of dudes with this very obsessive interest in fly fishing. So fly fishing, I thought was about, I don't know what it was. I thought it was just like about having fancy gear and about like repeatedly casting and casting and casting. And what I found about fly fishing was what's interesting is that it's actually a sport about attention.
我了解得越多，就越钦佩它。你能谈谈奋斗型游戏中的飞钓吗？是的。飞钓对我来说真的很有趣。所以我在犹他州，在犹他州，有很多家伙对飞钓有着非常痴迷的兴趣。所以飞钓，我以为是关于，我不知道它是什么。我以为它只是关于拥有昂贵的装备，关于反复地抛投、抛投再抛投。而我发现关于飞钓，有趣的是它实际上是一项关于注意力的运动。
So what you're doing if you're fly fishing, especially in the style I like, which is dry fly fishing, which is where you're trying to get a fish to swim up and eat a bug off the surface, what you're often doing is walking along a river, in a river, looking for either actually being able to see a trout rising or being able to see the quality of water where a trout is likely to be under the water. And then you have to figure out what kind of bugs it's feeding, which means you have to be really attentive. to what is hatching in the air, which can change every 20 minutes. And so what the game does is it forces you to hyper focus on small, subtle visual details across a huge ecological landscape. And one of the things I found interesting is if I go to a river without the fly fishing game, I look at the river for like a minute and then I'm bored and I look away. if you give me the game, then I can zero in on the surface of the water
所以如果你在飞钓，特别是我喜欢的风格，即干式飞钓（dry fly fishing），也就是你试图让鱼游上来吃掉水面上的虫子，你经常做的是沿着河走，在河里，寻找实际上能看到鳟鱼跃起，或者能够看到鳟鱼可能在水下的水质。然后你必须弄清楚它在吃什么样的虫子，这意味着你必须非常专注。注意空气中正在孵化什么，这可能每20分钟就会改变一次。所以游戏所做的是，它迫使你高度专注于整个巨大生态景观中微小、细微的视觉细节。我发现有趣的一件事是，如果我不带飞钓游戏去河边，我盯着河看一分钟，然后我就无聊了，我就看向别处。如果你给我这个游戏，那么我就可以锁定水面，
and have focus for hours. And it's really like two or three hours into focusing intensely on a river that I achieve like, I don't know, like these like weird altered mental states of complete like zend out brain water have flowed together. But I think it's really funky.
并专注几个小时。真的就像在专注地盯着河看两三个小时后，我达到了，我不知道，就像这些奇怪的改变了的精神状态，完全像禅定一样，大脑和水融为一体。但我认为这真的很时髦。
Like the game is a support structure for that kind of attention. It's very hard to get there on your own. When I try seated meditation, I can't get there. If someone's like, pay attention to the river until your mind empties and merges to the river, I'd be like, I have no idea how to do that. What? But if someone's like, look for trout and then notice what insects are and then try to cast,
就像游戏是那种注意力的支撑结构。你自己很难达到那种状态。当我尝试静坐冥想时，我无法达到。如果有人说，注意河流直到你的思想清空并与河流融合，我会说，我不知道该怎么做。什么？但如果有人说，寻找鳟鱼，然后注意昆虫是什么，然后尝试抛投，
then that's like a little tangible thread that I can crawl my way into this subtle. subtle mental state. One of the interesting things about games is you don't need to understand them for them to act on you, right? Like what a game is is it tells you to do something and it gives you some constraints. And you're like, I don't know, what's that for? And you just try it. Do it, yeah. And then suddenly you have these discoveries of, I see this all the time.
那么这就是一条我可以爬进这种微妙精神状态的小而有形的线索。游戏有趣的一点是，你不需要理解它们，它们就能对你产生作用，对吧？游戏就是告诉你做某事，并给你一些限制。你会说，我不知道，那是为了什么？然后你只是尝试。去做，是的。然后突然之间，你有了这些发现，我一直看到这种情况。
Like people playing Dungeons and Dragons for the first time, playing like a social communication. party game like the mind for the first time, trying rock climbing for the first time. They don't know what it's for. They don't know the reason why anyone would do it. Someone talked to them to do it. They try it. And the rules kind of force them into an intentional posture of looking at the world and seeking out, looking for holds in the rock, looking for little bugs in the air.
比如人们第一次玩《龙与地下城》，第一次玩像《The Mind》这样的社交沟通派对游戏，第一次尝试攀岩。他们不知道那是为了什么。他们不知道为什么有人会做这件事。有人告诉他们去做。他们尝试了。规则强迫他们进入一种有意的姿势，去观察世界并寻找，寻找岩石上的抓点，寻找空气中的小虫子。
And suddenly they're doing that. And then something happens to their mind and body. And they find that there's some like weird, new, radiant kind of beauty that they hadn't known about. and that they couldn't have chased directly. This is the magic of games. More it with T. Wynne after this. We're back with C.T. Wynn.
突然之间，他们就在做那件事了。然后他们的身心发生了一些变化。他们发现有一种奇怪的、新的、灿烂的美，他们以前不知道。而且他们无法直接追求到。这就是游戏的魔力。稍后继续与C.T. 温探讨。我们回到与C.T. 温的对话。
I'm really interested in how to use metrics for good because objective measures and transparencies are key components to good government, progressive era politics. And we've talked about Robert Moses a lot on the show. And before he became the villain of the power broker, he was champion civil service reform. And that's all about measuring achievement,
我非常感兴趣如何将指标用于善，因为客观衡量和透明度是良好政府、进步时代政治的关键组成部分。我们在节目中谈论过很多罗伯特·摩西（Robert Moses）。在他成为《权力掮客》（The Power Broker）中的反派之前，他曾是公务员制度改革的拥护者。而这完全是关于衡量成就，
taking tests and making sure people got jobs because they deserve them and not because they were someone's nephew. So how do we use scores and scoring systems in an effective way to make the world a better place and have them not dominate our lives in a bad way? One of the most famous cases, I think, is the quantification of policing in New York police districts. So in the early days, people said, like, look,
参加考试并确保人们因为应得而获得工作，而不是因为他们是某人的侄子。那么我们如何以有效的方式使用分数和评分系统来让世界变得更美好，并让它们不会以糟糕的方式主导我们的生活呢？我认为最著名的案例之一是纽约警察局的警务量化。所以早些时候，人们说，看，
all these police districts say that they're doing, well, we can't tell if they're doing well. So we're going to put clear metrics about what we can measure, which is how many cases get closed, right? How many arrests do we make? And what happened was in the first bunch of years, it worked great. It detected all kinds of corruption, it declared all kinds of bias, and it forced people to rid it, get that out of the system. And then after a little while, I think in a story that a lot of people know that I learned from the TV show The Wire. Right.
所有这些警察局都说他们做得很好，我们无法判断他们是否做得好。所以我们将制定关于我们能衡量什么的明确指标，即有多少案件结案，对吧？我们进行了多少次逮捕？结果在最初的几年里，它运作得很好。它检测到了各种腐败，揭露了各种偏见，并迫使人们清除它，将其从系统中剔除。然后过了一会儿，我想在一个很多人都知道的故事里，我从电视剧《火线》（The Wire）中学到的。对吧。
Same. People started like gaming those metrics, right? You can game those metrics easily. One way to make your case closure rate look good is to discourage people from reporting crimes, right? One way to up your case closure rate is speeding tickets because you open the case and you close it at the same time. So in the beginning, it gets rid of corruption and bias because the metrics are so brute that everyone can understand them. Yeah. And after a period of time, they seem to.
一样。人们开始像玩游戏一样操纵那些指标，对吧？你可以很容易地操纵那些指标。让你的结案率看起来不错的一种方法是劝阻人们报告犯罪，对吧？提高结案率的一种方法是开超速罚单，因为你打开案件的同时也就结案了。所以一开始，它消除了腐败和偏见，因为指标非常粗糙，每个人都能理解它们。是的。而在一段时间后，它们似乎，
drain what's genuinely valuable from the system because they point people at something that's very easily and mechanically checkable and measurable. So in T's police an example, metrics start out as being helpful and in service of offering transparency to the public, but eventually they end up being counterproductive and sometimes even dangerous. And he told me that a similar dynamic can play out with population-wide statistics where you're trying to get a sense of trends on a really big scale. What makes metrics work well is that they work at scale really fast, so they're really good for us to coordinate around for vast social efforts.
从系统中耗尽了真正有价值的东西，因为它们引导人们去关注一些非常容易、机械地可检查和可衡量的事情。所以在温教授的警察例子中，指标一开始是有帮助的，旨在为公众提供透明度，但最终它们变得适得其反，有时甚至很危险。他告诉我，类似的动态也会在全人口统计数据中上演，当你试图在大规模范围内了解趋势时。指标运作良好的原因是它们在大规模范围内运作得非常快，所以它们非常适合我们围绕巨大的社会努力进行协调。
So if you're going to coordinate the entire world around reducing CO2 emissions or increasing vaccination rates, right, that's a really simple thing. And when we count it in the same way, we can cooperate really easily. The cost is there are only certain kinds of things that we all measure in the same way and count in the same way, that we can, coordinate around. So here's, that suggests another answer, which is that some kinds of targets are naturally stable at scale and easy for everyone to count at scale, and it's easier to get good metrics of that. So I'll give you an example. It's much easier to get a good metric for lifespan and mortality rate than it is to get a metric for mental health. Everyone counts lifespan and deaths in the same way, these other things aren't counted in the same way.
所以如果你要协调全世界围绕减少二氧化碳排放或提高疫苗接种率，对吧，那是一件非常简单的事情。当我们以同样的方式计算它时，我们可以非常容易地合作。代价是只有某些类型的事情是我们都以同样的方式衡量和计算的，我们才能围绕它们进行协调。所以，这暗示了另一个答案，即某些类型的目标在大规模上自然是稳定的，并且每个人在大规模上都很容易计算，而且更容易获得好的指标。所以我给你举个例子。获得寿命和死亡率的良好指标比获得心理健康的指标要容易得多。每个人都以同样的方式计算寿命和死亡，而这些其他事情并没有以同样的方式计算。
So it is appropriate in those cases because the kind of thing that's being targeted is the kind of thing that's stable at scale. But the worry, the price is that we tend to socially over attend to those qualities, that we over attend to lifespan and mortality rate instead of mental well-being, flourishing, community, flourishing, social relationships. So I guess the point I'm wondering is, is like, what do we do with all this? Like, how do we live and thrive in a world where we have no choice but to engage with these metrics in so many areas in our lives? Yeah, so I would like to give you the peppy answer of like just grit up and play with the institutions your lives.
所以在这些情况下它是合适的，因为被针对的事情是那种在大规模上稳定的事情。但担忧，代价是我们倾向于在社会上过度关注这些品质，我们过度关注寿命和死亡率，而不是心理健康、繁荣、社区、繁荣、社会关系。所以我猜我想知道的一点是，我们该如何处理这一切？比如，我们如何在一个别无选择，只能在生活中的许多领域与这些指标打交道的世界中生活和繁荣？是的，所以我想给你一个活泼的回答，比如振作起来，玩转你生活中的机构。
But that's not, I mean, I think one of the things we know is that if you quit a game, nothing happens. And if you quit your KPI's or your, you know, other metrics in your work, you get fired. and then you starve and then your family died. It's not the same. But I think you can still, there are a few things you can do. One thing you can do is at least have some ironic distance. I think there's a huge difference between someone thinking, my goal in life is to have the most subscribers versus my goal is to communicate and have all these other things.
但这并不是，我的意思是，我认为我们知道的一件事是，如果你退出一个游戏，什么都不会发生。但如果你退出工作中的KPI或其他指标，你会被解雇。然后你会挨饿，然后你的家人会死。这不一样。但我认为你仍然可以，有几件事你可以做。你可以做的一件事是至少保持一些反讽的距离。我认为一个人认为“我的人生目标是拥有最多的订阅者”与“我的目标是沟通并拥有所有这些其他东西，我需要订阅者来做到这一点，但我愿意为此做出权衡”之间有巨大的区别，对吧？这是一件事。不过，温教授最后告诉我的，是我在被指标定义的世界中生活而不让它们定义自己的最喜欢的方法。他谈到了在生活中找到一些小地方，你可以选择创造或定义自己的指标，这让你能够设计你真正想玩的游戏。我一直在抱怨指标，然后我意识到我负责为我的学生制定一个巨大的指标，为我的学生制定的评分系统是我拥有权威的评分系统，而我只是
And I need subscribers to do it, but I'm willing to trade off against it, right? That's one thing. The last thing, T-T-T-T. me about, though, was my favorite approach to living in a world defined by metrics without letting them define you. He talked about finding little places in your life where you can choose to create or define your own metrics, which lets you design the game you actually want to be playing. I complained about metrics forever, and then I realized I was in charge of a huge one for my students, migrating system for my students, is a scoring system that I am an authority and I was just
在做一个不假思索的威权主义者。所以这可能会让你觉得有趣，但在过去的两年里，当我思考这个问题时，我决定我没有意识到，当我抱怨指标的暴政时，我转过身来却把它强加给了我的学生。所以我一直在尝试一个实验。我一直在让我的学生设计他们自己的评分系统。所以我在我的技术与设计伦理课上所做的是走进去说，我们谁都不知道在课堂上该怎么处理ChatGPT。
being an unthinking authoritarian. And so this might amuse you, but the last two years, as I've been thinking about this, I decided that I had not realized the degree to which, as I complained about the tyranny of metrics, I was turning around and imposing it on my students. And so I've been trying an experiment. I have been letting my students design their own scoring system. So what I've been doing in my tech and design ethics class is walking in and saying, none of us have any clue what to do about chat GPT in the classroom.
所以作为课堂练习，我们将讨论教育、人工智能和民主的哲学，然后他们将民主地设计他们自己的评分系统和课堂作业。这是我一直可以做的事情，但我没有意识到。进展如何？太棒了。难以置信。让我告诉你。首先，过程重于结果。
And so as an exercise in the class, we will talk about the philosophy of education, AI, and democracy, and then they will democratically design their own grading system and assignments for the class. And that's something I could have done all along, and I didn't realize it. How did that go? Amazing. Unbelievable. Let me tell you. first of all, process over outcome.
他们设计的评分系统实际上相当不错。但提出它的过程比我做过的任何其他作业都更有价值。哇。他们投入了这么多。他们最终认真讨论了教育是为了什么，评分系统是为了什么，人工智能的使用是为了什么，这一切意味着什么。他们非常认真地对待它。而且我认为，除其他事项外，它教会了他们系统思维。他们开始思考评分系统的设计如何改变了教育，
The grading system they designed was actually quite good. But the process of coming up with it was more valuable than any other assignment I've ever done. Wow. They get so invested. And they ended up talking seriously about what an education was for, what a grading system was for, what the use of AI was for, what all of it meant. They took it super seriously. And I think, among other things, it taught them systems thinking. They started having to think about how the design of a grading system changed in education
以及你如何获得好的和坏的设计。而且我认为我试图做的一部分是让学生看到你试图让人们看到的东西，那就是所有这些在后台安静的设计情况完全改变了人们的互动方式。比如，从某种意义上说，谁在乎呢？我的意思是，他们确实提出了一个好的评分系统，但我有点不在乎他们是否提出了，因为提出它的过程实际上让我得到了我最初从这门课中想要的东西。我和你谈话非常愉快。我喜欢这本书，《得分》。
and how you get good and bad design. And I think part of what I was trying to do was get students to see what you're trying to get people to see, which is that all these quiet design situations in the background totally change how people interact. Like, who cares in some sense? I mean, they did come up with a good grading system, but I kind of don't care if they did because the process of coming up with it actually got me what I wanted from the class in the first place. I had just a great time talking with you. I love the book, The Score.
我只是，我读得非常开心，而且我非常喜欢审视它并用它来解码我的生活和我的选择。我真的很感激。谢谢。非常感谢。本周的《99% Invisible》由Lashma Donne制作，Kelly Prime编辑。Martine Gonzalez混音，Swan Rial配乐。Kathy 2是我们的执行制片人。Kurt Colstead是我们的数字总监。
I just, I had so much fun reading it, and I had so much fun sort of like looking at it and using it to decode my life and my choices. I really appreciate it. Thank you. Thank you so much. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Lashma Donne and edited by Kelly Prime. Mixed by Martine Gonzalez, music by Swan Rial. Kathy 2 is our executive producer. Kurt Colstead is our digital director.
Delaney Hall是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括Chris Barube、Jason DeLeon、Emmett Fitzgerald、Christopher Johnson、Vivian Leigh、Joe Rosenberg、Jacob Medina Gleason、Tallinn和Rain Stradley，以及我，罗曼·马斯。《99% Invisible》的标志由Stefan Lawrence创作。我们是SiriusXM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于北边六个街区的Pandora大楼。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。那里有一个链接，以及《99% Invisible》的每一期往期节目。
Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barube, Jason DeLeon. Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Joe Rosenberg, Jacob Medina Gleason, Tallinn and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99P.
在99PI.org。这一集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请访问 99PI.org。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。